it's so good to see you first of all
nice to see you you were about to give
this amazing panel if people take away
one message from what you have to say
today what do you hope that is I want
women in general to believe that they
can do anything they put their minds to
if they have goals dreams aspirations no
matter where you are in your life
meaning you didn't go to college because
you had kids right away or you were just
a stay-at-home mom for a while and
you're like I don't know if I could be
that entrepreneur or be that CEO that
I've always wanted to be I want the
women here to walk away feeling
empowered and yes yes what uh what
empowers you oh my gosh you know what
empowers me is just being in a room with
all of these women I feel like when I
inspire women I'm inspiring and
encouraging and empowering myself so
when I'm in a room with women coming
together with one cause which is
basically just to empower one another to
inspire one another
that's what empowerment is to me so I'm
so excited to be here I I'm I'm always
thrilled to be a part of any event that
Creighton cultivate does because that's
what it's about it's about a community
and building a community of so many
great women and learning from one
another collaborating there's
collaborations that happen when we're in
this room I've befriended so many people
I have new friends they're just always
in your corner just saying you got this
girl and it's just it's empowering I
mean you're such a strong woman
businesswoman like you kind of do it all
yeah what do you hope to teach your
daughter when it comes to that you know
I always say you know because I have two
children I have a son and I have a
daughter my son is a part of me but my
daughter is and is an extension of me I
want my daughter to
yawns she's very young too yeah soon I
want her to grow up knowing that she has
a voice knowing that she has a lot to
say and knowing that she can do anything
that she wants to do whatever she puts
her mind to the world is hers that's
what I want my daughter to you know to
grow up and knowing I also want her to
love unconditionally I feel like the
world needs it and when you are an
example it's very healing to the world
so I just want her to be strong loving
and just you know be all that she can be
yeah you are talking about turning your
platform into profit today how are you
able to really turn your Instagram into
this leg business like we love following
you and your authenticity you know you
said it many people they always ask what
is your secret and I always say my
secret especially in a world of
celebrity I think people tend to look at
perfection and you know everything kind
of just being perfect and that's not me
I have to be Who I am and authenticity
is the key for me I'm very vulnerable
I'm very relatable in the sense that if
I'm going through postpartum depression
I'm not afraid to say it if I've gained
60 pounds after having a baby I'm like
this is me this is who I am you know
embrace it and I think it's it's it's
something that the world needs and and
it's very refreshing so you know I've
just stayed true true to who I am and I
don't follow trends do you know what I
mean like I've been in this business for
25 years over 25 years and I've never
been that type to be like oh this is hot
right now so I'm gonna do this so be
this well this is hot right now I mean
no I'm just Who I am and there's only
one you
so when you embrace who you are you will
always win
so yeah you did recently post pictures
of you you cut your hair
I did I did I did I know ok can I be
really honest so basically I'm working
on this project and they wanted long
hair so I didn't have time to everybody
this is a wig ok
authenticity it's yeah you know I mean
that's the coolest thing too about short
hair you can you can do anything you
want but that's why I don't have my
short hair right now cuz I was working
on a project that they wanted long hair
project I can't say but you guys it's
coming out soon and I'm so freaking and
fine and you'll know you'll know maybe
like in July or August that's when I
believe it'll be pushed and announced it
is one of my dreams and it's good and I
kept I had a try it's one of my dreams
and I and I cannot wait to share with
the world so not to bring things down
but I think you yeah I think you did say
you cut your hair you were inspired
after coat yeah what was it about that
I've learned so much from this whole
experience and I believe that so many
other people have and I don't feel like
I'm the same person after that so I just
wanted to just kind of get rid of the
old and start with the new
I've always been appreciative person and
but I've never really been the person to
walk around and understand that anything
can happen you know what I mean like you
could be here one minute and gone the
next and it's out of your control so I
was like I just need to get rid of this
energy I need to just I'm not that
person anymore and so I just wanted to
just cut my hair off
yeah that's why and I mean not to harp
on it but we're also affected and I know
that you spent time with him he was on
Sister Sister of course oh Kobe
[Music]
[Applause]
I am working on family reunion and we're
at Paramount Studios and I shot the
episode with Kobe Bryant at Paramount
Studios on stage 24 and I walked over
there stage 24 stage 24 I walked over
there on stage 24 there was they were
working on something but they weren't in
production and I said may I come on the
stage say yeah come on in and I
literally stood right where we had stood
together when we had done that scene and
the one thing that I remember about that
scene is its I mean his legacy is the
whole you know the Mamba mentality and
he had that at 18 he came on set and my
sister and I were like you're not
nervous
it wasn't nervous he knew his lines he
stood on his mark he was like what and
we were like this dude is a beast and he
so yeah he
it's it's it's very I'm still dealing
with it to be honest with you it's it's
hard to grasp the reality of it all but
the legacy that he has left behind is so
amazing so incredible what he's done for
women's basketball the youth inspiring
people he's continuing to inspire me
yeah so you'd be there on Monday no no I
will not be there on Monday no I was at
the all-star game and they did an
incredible tribute there and then my
husband was also at the first game for
the Laker game yeah you want to say to
help us remember him the way that you
will always remember him just you know
to continue to remember his legacy and
what he left behind which is that Mamba
mentality which and how I take it is
don't even just go for first go for the
best of the best of the best of the best
continue to push yourself further than
you could even have imagined that you
can go and that's what I just want to
you know continue to meditate on and for
others to meditate on that you know you
can do anything that you put your mind
to as long and what I liked about him
too was he was he also believed and you
had to work hard to get there you know
what I mean it wasn't like just be the
best no it was about you got to work
hard to get there and understand those
work ethic so I'm continuing to embrace
that with me and myself and you know
continue to work hard it's not gonna
come there it's not gonna you're not
gonna get it easy but it will get there
you will get there if you continue to
work
so yeah I'm sharing that seriously like
I'm not to come you know like yeah meet
you
yeah no specials oh yeah thank you will
be missed but never forgotten